[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he wants to make this about hop let's do
this yeah oh yeah they're starting early
though they're start early if they happy
over there play nuts a fire working a
little one you know how it's gonna
explode you know what's gonna happen
here
gunfire advances our site still looks
great yeah
[Applause]
crowd talking Wow
Jody says it's what Evan thinks it's
over
[Applause]
Wow this is absolutely impressive
my goodness wait what about McDonnell
Aires that is a bad he's doing it again
look at mine Wow switching techniques
I love this simple easier second let's
try this starting to rip up looking
deadly pull it right back in there we go
back this up close your hands shoulder
bat your emotions get the best be me
right there's this Devin set just beat
it but it's gotta be a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody knows why you hate your job to
fight me you let go of me we're not what
are you pulling back for I'm putting our
center
close your cups not gonna play the game
wash your hands
[Applause]
I'm speechless just watching this
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three what's one more really
working it's not the first [ __ ] time
one-nothing Devin lair with a lead close
your thumbs finger man you don't want to
come in a fight with a bad finger I find
you new here in this main event the
fifth round would just be a story tale
that just you know it it would just make
the dramatics so perfect but right now
Devon's in match coordinate is that
legal
[Laughter]
like the elbow you can't get ready he
didn't he said stop go man all dev wants
is a go right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just staring him down
[Applause]
[Music]
davin lair wins it 3-1
and again defeats all right so what is
next for you I mean I've seen you at all
these events
who can beat Devin Larry does that
person exist of course that person
exists of course he does you saw how
close that was and now it's only Matt
[Applause]
your boy quit your boy quit round one
Bob no limits Larry no
[Applause]
[Music]
don't all the commands will be pulling
you across you're not looking to do to
be fair I think he's got a case there
doesn't look like he's off-center he's
just trying to keep his in the center of
the table from where he can would cause
the foul on Devon Lera
Devin Melanie very aggressive individual
issues to combat situation so it feels
like at the moment he's not getting a
fair crack of the whip in terms of
position and in typical burries have got
at least 20 people like a jump start
until he finished it there he was off
early they're dragging each other and
it's getting a little physical oh yeah
Chafee with one pin
[Music]
[Applause]
he's a dragster now have you looked up
the - it's a dragster against a rally
car right when it's on a straight cable
and dragster asked the speed right now
the road is it going Pete and Dave
Chaffee is feeling it now
Devin were pitting there he wants you to
pin himself he wants to embarrass him
the tables falling apart
[Applause]
Devin's got him they're talking about
sportsmanship there and yesterday he
said Devin is working very hard here
believe me he's trying to call him and
he's trying to bounce Dave back David
just giving himself needs to look not a
warm pink pressure there but he said I
never is the sacrifice Devin look he's
baiting it he's talking to him three
fouls
and it's again for Devin and Devin
wasn't attacking back there yeah he was
letting Dave feel like he was in the
match he was letting Dave attack and
burst his energy wide open Davis very
light left now de valera mocking him
because he utilized Mike's all move that
y'all move up game position yep and
that's not intentionally stood to gain
as much body
Devin talking to you
adjust this position very very ugly much
to watch intentionally there allow Devon
the opportunity to pin him he looked for
the way out and fouled himself out of
the match yeah you know what he wanted
to know is how he died about this wrist
because he wanted to test the strength
[Applause]
completely he can have his way with come
on yuge it was earlier if I stop the map
I'm happy come on over here the control
on you yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
exactly as we expected better yeah he
felt enough from Wagner to think you
know what
this isn't a guy I'm gonna give anymore
let's put it away
[Applause]